[Music]
how many of these videos are there
i i can't take it oh guys you're
depressing me today you can actually
pinpoint the second when his heart rips
in half
and now
all righty folks we are back for another
round of never-ending torture from my
producers they have cold the worst of
tick-tock they're gonna force me to
watch these like it's a clockwork orange
and i'm going to respond to them so
prepare for the suffering
i'm just going to post this every time
people ask me the same questions over
and over again my name is farah i am a
trans woman as well as an intersex woman
my pronouns are she her they them are
your grace
my eyes are tattooed
my nose is a piercing
i identify as a threat a nightmare and a
goddess so please bow down to me i do
not believe in god i don't worship the
devil but yes i am a satanist which
means i am my own god and i worship
myself
thank you have a good day
the last part's true you need to do this
you really must worship yourself but but
i'm the best i have questions just about
you know decision making
i have questions about
what happens when you have a cold but
you have a giant hole that you have put
in the side of your nose with apparently
some sort of heart hole punch
i i just have i have many questions none
of them are honestly i'm not sure i want
to hear the answers i i mostly just want
to
bury my head under a pillow and scream i
think so i saw this video of a cop
forcibly removing a mass subway commuter
for asking him to put on a map at first
i was confused because there are signs
all over the subway stations and subway
cars asking people to wear a mask but
then it occurred to me maybe the nypd
don't know how to read so i skated to my
local mass scan in chinatown to pick up
some mass for them and myself because
unemployment benefits ended and the
government deems the economy more
important than human lives doesn't mean
that we're not still in a pandemic i
went to dunkin donuts to get some pig
bait i thought my look was giving but
not everyone seemed to agree finally i
hopped the turnstile like all new
yorkers do if you're upset that i
committed fair evasion i just want to
let you know i'm just following the
examples of the pigs in this video
previously when i tried to give them
masks as it was mandated on their job as
cases were skyrocketing they refused
them so this time i got creative and
attached mass to a fishing pole with
donuts as bait and finally it was time
for me to go fishing okay they say we
don't have enough of a social welfare
net here in the united states let me
just point out that this human being
spent their entire day doing this and
putting it on tick tock and somehow is
still
gonna have enough to eat for dinner so i
would suggest that we need to change our
incentive structure maybe you should get
a jab all these videos are just filled
with with practical questions like how
do you skateboard in those heels
if i'm a cop nothing says i'm going to
comply with your demands that i wear a
mask quite like you giving me
quote-unquote pig bait what delights
these
are you guys
so i have this thing call it a little
quirk if you will i have hair in my
armpits i have it there for a few
reasons one lazy two
the patriarchy and three
your response to them tells me
everything i need to know about you
don't worry they're not seeking
attention no one none of these people
are seeking attention it's amazing they
just they they demand nothing of you
right this was the argument wasn't this
always the argument the argument was
they're not demanding they just want to
live life the way they want to live life
except they demand your full acceptance
if you look at people and you say um
it's strange that you have decided to
shave the front of your head leave a
ponytail and leave your armpits unshaven
while wearing sleeveless shirts that's
my problem it seems like more it's your
problem don't demand my attention and
then when i give you the attention you
get very offended by the attention it's
the most childish crap ever seriously
it's super childish it's what my it's
what my five-year-old does
insubordinate and churlish act like
children be treated like children
seriously
[Music]
this is our man i feel bad for this kid
i seriously i feel bad for the kid
and then there will be a kid born into a
family without a proper father mother
that's sad
here's the thing
it's all fun and games until two
generations from now there are no
children and our society is a complete
wreck and waste of itself there are
other societies that have not decided to
carve out the heart from maleness and
femaleness and those societies will
continue to thrive and exist ours simply
will not we'll get to more woke tick
tocks in just one moment first let's
talk about how daily wire was built when
we started daily wire it literally was
like seven of us in a pool house filming
my podcast but then we decided we were
going to grow and the way to grow was we
had to focus in on data we had to focus
in on marketing we needed to make smart
business decisions that were data driven
and every company needs to do that
every company strives to have unique
values and a long lasting impact it's
time to position your company as an
industry leader create buzz attract new
customers and generate consistent
revenue giant partners is here to help
you do it giant partners are america's
number one data-driven marketing agency
they operate in the business to business
space offering a variety of business
marketing solutions like database
marketing brand development web design
seo lead generation digital marketing
services and ad placement that's just to
name a few of their services whether you
own a small family business or handle
millions in revenue every year giant
partners can help you get to the next
level their marketing strategies are
research driven they're equipped with 20
years of data experience don't take my
word for it their largest customers
include bmw nationwide ohio state
university 3m and ethan allen so head on
over to giantpartners.com get your
business set up today
so i am a cis woman with ibs and i use
the men's bathroom and i've seen a lot
of videos of trans men who are in bath
public bathroom stalls with somebody in
assault next to them just farting and
and being grossed i have a
question stop it right there why are
there videos online of people in stalls
in bathrooms period doesn't that make
you the perv also what else are you
supposed to do in a bathroom stall
i mean aside from like if you're larry
craig and you're actually like trying to
solicit some sort of action in a public
restroom uh what are you supposed to be
doing except for taking a dump in the
toilet that's right buddy you show that
turtle's boss okay we can continue but i
don't know why we're continuing no i
don't want to i want to run directly
through this wall leaving a ben
shapiro-sized hole in the wall that's
what i want to do right now
and it just makes me think about this
time that i was in the walmart bathroom
just having a bad ibs episode in the
men's bathroom um and i was the one just
blowing it up and it wasn't until much
later
that um there was i noticed there was
just a silent guy in the stall like very
like after like five minutes of just me
being disgusting i hear like a little
shift and i'm like and so every time i
see those videos of trans guys talking
about how gross men are in the bathroom
i never want to be invalidating but i
want to be like what if it's a woman it
could be a woman it could be me what if
it's me
so that's the takeaway the takeaway is
that women take dumps too that's
impossible yeah
yeah how many of these videos are there
i i can't take it my my brain cells are
all dying by the time we get to the end
of these tick tock videos i will not be
a functional human being i'm just going
to be babbling in cream of wheat like
joe biden by the time you've destroyed
all of my neuronal connections no new
once november here's everything that's
wrong with america let's go firstly for
context my name's emma i live in
australia and i have degrees in
sociology and law okay stop for a second
one degree in sociology you're a
professional useless person two you're
in australia i don't want to hear about
your opinions on what's wrong with
america i don't give a sh
i really don't care like are you you're
busily locked down
like for the 900th consecutive day
on on an island like congratulations to
you why would i one of my favorite
things about the left is that they think
that i give any at all about what
foreigners think of the united states
like i do not care i do i could not care
less number one in a surprise to no one
what's wrong with america guns y'all are
obsessed with your right to bear arms
here's a concept
i don't give a sh
the feeling is mutual lady
why do i care about your feelings about
our right to bear arms guns i don't like
your guns well good you live in
australia stay there no one asked you do
you see this person next to me
he is my friend
zias had to put up with a lot to get to
where per is today i just want to let
glint know that thon is valid that her
pronouns are valid and that sarah
identity is valid
i wish void all the best and look
forward to maybe even seeing some of
their lovely content someday please
treat them with respect and i'm sure a
will respect you too
is there a person next to this person
they said e is next to
jim
which is next to void
which is next to zurby
ver
e
u
i have no idea what that was uh maybe
it's a brilliant form of really like i
made a clockwork orange reference before
we even begin i'm wondering if this is
just like a brilliant new form of sci-fi
that is filled with you know various new
terms like you're having a a milk but
it's it's it's an actual like alcoholic
beverage and i just i don't know what i
go just go is this last one please god
is this the last one
so there's two you lied to me
more no nuance november i guess
this one is simply
if i'm pissing off ben shapiro i must be
doing something right you haven't pissed
me off i don't i don't understand who
you are which which person is this
pronouns
disease answers there's or really any
neo pronouns that's the same person well
i'm glad this person grew out their hair
so that's that's good i'm i'm proud of
jesus void mce we've crossed all
barriers now they make tick-tock videos
i respond to the tic-tac videos and then
they completely change into different
characters and respond to my tic-tac
videos and then i respond to their
tic-tac videos it's an infinite regress
of brain melting stupidity
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
little fellas just lost his will to live
i got i got nothing for you this is no
longer cute you need to go get a job
stop being dependent on the public dime
all of you people on tech talk go get
jobs become productive humans enter into
meaningful relationships go do something
useful with your lives please for the
love of god
well
now that um what is left of my
brain
what is left in my brain is not allowing
me to say words in
sentences anymore yeah guys you keep
going this way you keep torturing me
this way you keep demanding in the
comments that i continue to make these
woke tick tock response videos you keep
doing this and you will get me to run
for president eventually and i will be
just as dysfunctional and non-functional
as the current president of the united
states just like there will be no brains
left in my head mr president have you
gone completely insane like a fox
i
tick-tock to linda asked i feel like i'm
taking crazy pills